[Music]
Melissa McCarthy is one of the funniest
people in the world and you know part of
what makes her so funny is all that wild
dangerous are you kidding me physical
comedy that we get to watch or do but
how much of that is really Melissa well
I found out
I try to do as much as I can until
someone who goes you're not doing that
what's the matter with you
when the stunt gets too crazy for
Melissa usually stepping in is this
woman thirty-five-year-old stunt woman
Luci Romberg what kind of injuries have
you had I've been super lucky over the
last 12 years I've only had to go to the
hospital once um there are some stitches
that's amazing when you consider shots
like this on identity thief
that's Melissa that's Lucy on
ghostbusters Melissa Lucy on the boss
directed by McCarthy's husband Ben
Falcone
that's Melissa you're gonna regret this
and that's Lucy she wants to do all the
stunts herself on the box we're doing
the section where she gets flowing
across against the wall off the bed and
she's like I can do it and her husband
amends like yeah you can do it once this
is so good Lucy took that hit but
amazingly on her famous Super Bowl
commercial Lucy says that's mostly
Melissa doing the stunt work we had her
falling down the crevice getting picked
up by the Rhino shook around when else
do you get to be picked up like a rag
doll and literally like thrown around
she can do the split she can I mean she
I saw that picture of you both in the
quits holy yeah yeah she's incredible
what has been the craziest stunt that
you and Melissa have done together I
would probably have to say the
helicopter sequence on spy getting to
hang from a helicopter and she killed it
- meaning a lot of that work was
McCarthy herself it took three days to
shoot that scene your hands go numb and
you have wear blisters and weirdly I
really love that stuff
Lucy stays in shape by freerunning it's
a competitive type of running that
includes gymnastics and acrobatics there
you just got show-off and praise me I
just had to try
[Music]
you